Let's see the different types of energy one by one.
Gravitational energy.
It is associated with gravity or gravitational force.
It is the energy held by an object because of its high position compared to a lower position.
For example, see these elephants?
This one has more gravitational potential energy as it is on higher ground.
And this one has less whereas gravitational force acting on both is the same.
Thermal or heat energy.
It is created from the vibration of molecules and atoms within substances.
The faster they move, the more energy they produce and the hotter they become.
Chemical energy.
It is the potential of a chemical substance that undergoes a transformation...
...through a chemical reaction to transform other chemical substances.
For example, the food we eat is digested to convert chemical energy...
...into other forms of energy used by cells.
Electrical energy.
It is generated by moving electric charges called electrons.
Lighting and electric cells are examples of electrical energy.
Radiant or light energy.
It is a form of electromagnetic radiation.
Light travels in waves and it's the only kind of energy humans can see.
For example, the energy from the Sun.